no you're right exceptions don't make no
sense to to the bigger Society but I'm
I'm always not always but I'm mostly
section to divorce when I say things I'm
thinking about how so when I say things
I'm thinking things how how I think and
how I react but I also understand that
Society doesn't think like me most girls
will quote exceptions not not the rule
and it's just to alleviate themselves of
the responsibility of having to be
factual in the moment do you think so
100 yeah
accountability is the one key word when
you throw that word around like how many
women really claim that and I could say
I'm truly accountable for my actions we
we all here just said once you ask the
question about um
um being of understanding the the
byproducts of certain decisions we make
and we all know that yeah we make
impulsive decisions yet you still make
the wrong decision so accountability
will tell you that okay to better myself
and make better decisions I'm gonna take
accountability for my bad decisions and
embed myself but you all willingly said
like oh no well I still make impulses no
but that doesn't mean that we don't
learn from previous things that we've
done in the same way that you learn from
like your aggressive behavior when you
were younger that doesn't mean that we
don't learn from that and are conscious
of our Behavior if that happens again
from from what I've seen I don't think
most girls do I think they go to toxic
relationship after toxic relationship
after a toxic relationship then at 28 29
when they're running out of time their
biological clock is ticking they run to
the nice guy but in terms of
relationships that's because they
haven't learned they haven't understood
what was wrong with the relationship
before
their own behavior right how many times
you have to learn no but they haven't
learned they don't know what what 20
times 40 times 50 times and if you could
put a cap on how many times because
people learn people no not only because
not for me I've been in certain
situations I'll never go back to so I
learned very quick very young probably
why I'm single now because if I was
going if I was going with the changes
and going with the flow I would probably
be the man now but I learned very young
very quickly that I have that
there's a lot of it wasn't right for me
I wasn't ready for relationship and when
I was young because therefore I took
myself out of that stuff and worked on
myself if I was just to go freeing it I
probably would be with someone else I
think there's a lot because it's like a
strong person right we'll take a step
back well I mean don't get me wrong some
girls do learn and make better decisions
but the problem is we're just thinking
about us because why does a man have to
deal with that but in the same why does
he have to deal with a girl that can't
learn young like why why wouldn't he
just marry a 22 year old because she's
yeah that's that's what also what's
crazy about that though you're saying
that but then men also prefer young
women that haven't learned that um
how what so exactly young women yeah and
they haven't learned they haven't
learned they haven't been through these
they haven't learned no boom they
haven't been through these problems that
that create more problems for me in the
future so whether or not you've learned
okay I can I can help to teach you the
right way to do things I don't want to
have to teach you the right way after
bear man I've run through you and then
it becomes more of a hassle for me to to
try and develop this relationship
because you have their problems do you
know okay I hear that to be fair I
understand GG
okay because there's two there's two
different kind of females there's
females that had a lot of sex on men and
they've had their body count is very
high there's females that have not had
such a lot of men and their body cat is
low I have friends in both sections I
know people in both sections
and in my experience
even though you're saying I don't wonder
if a woman has been ran through whatever
and all those kind of things I have met
women I've had they've done the right
thing they've got less Partners they're
being submissive they've been all these
things but their man is still growing
and has go through things that he would
have gone through with a girl who's been
ran through because it's how I think
it's hard I've been treated by by people
which reflects on how you have to come
and deal with that mess so do you or
you're you're basically saying that the
girl with less bodies still has trauma
is that your problem yes yeah yeah but
we're talking about like a balance of
probabilities so if a girl's been with
50 dudes versus five dudes who's who's
more likely going to have more trauma
yeah the balance of probabilities
and you know I mean I've always said I
like Rolo tomasi has a quote where it's
like it's not the number it's the number
of like guys that she saw Alpha as Alpha
so it's like the number of men that
she's comparing you to but the bigger
the number is the more it's just a
balance of probabilities but when like
when you were talking earlier about
dating and sex like if sex is just a
physical act you can sleep with a guy
that you're not dating and that whether
that be a one-night stand or just a
fling like why does that necessarily
need to affect you in that way that it
puts you through trauma it doesn't you
can do that yeah like that's totally
fine but men don't want to deal with
that
again the characteristics of a woman
that frees it up to that capacity is
gonna have other implications in that
relationship and again why would you as
a man want to take that risk what kind
of implications are we talking about
here so if we're talking about like
promiscuity and the effect it can have
on a relationship
if that man isn't taking all the
biological boxes whereas he probably
would be would have been before if the
woman was less promiscuous the
likelihood is that she's more likely to
stay we caught the statistic before that
70 to 80 of women leave their men it's
not men leaving it's women leaving so if
men are out here having more sex and
women are having more sex but the
consequence of us both having more sex
you're less likely to stay with me then
what you're doing is causing a problem
to successful relationships so you're
actively breaking up nuclear homes
because you can't maintain your
discipline and women are leaving because
of sex then because of financial reasons
that we said so it's not about I don't I
mean did you know one of the number one
indicators of divorce is the woman out
earning the man I can see that yeah but
it goes back to because the woman one of
the reasons is because the woman is
around all these men that she wants but
then no but then if if we're talking
about is it is it sex or is it money
because if it's if she's if she's
leaving because he's not earned enough
that's different than this no that's
selfish but that's it's about being a
selfish woman that is selfish if you're
leaving and breaking up at home because
he's not earning enough money that's
selfish it's okay to want that but if
you if you sign the papers if you got
married to him and now you think you're
above him because you make more I
remember quite sure but we're talking
about characteristics here so yeah with
the characteristics of a woman that
wants to free up for everybody when she
is around me that she wants she's going
to act in those those feelings whereas a
woman who's more disciplined is able to
say no to things because she's had less
and they say that 20 of men are raising
a kid that's not theirs that's why they
don't want to promiscuous woman they're
afraid they're going to pass the
resources on to the wrong
um onto a kid that's not there well
unknowing or knowing not knowing so how
do they get the statistic I don't know
it's DNA tests
when they find out I just want to know
how that was how that was possible we
looked free sports a lady yesterday that
said that the guy was the kid was 11
years old before you found out the woman
just came clean because unconscious
couldn't take it no more mad this is
what man have to go through do you think
they wow do you think the woman
stay or do you think they settle because
it's like if they've been exposed to
airbnc men one toxic one really nice
they know how then to spot a really nice
guy and a toxic one whereas like if
they've had maybe one boyfriend and
that's the only toxic one they've had
that's the only familiarity they've had
with a partner do you know what I mean
so sometimes having say a promiscuous
girl they have that knowledge now you
see what you go ahead like men do
because you're saying now men can spread
their seeds so they know what they want
logically that makes sense yeah then we
have the data to prove that that doesn't
work so what you're saying would be make
sense in an ideal world but ideally that
doesn't actually happen I mean as many
of you know I was just banned on Tic Tac
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible